what were you doing at her age I was not
I didn't know what I wanted to do at
your age I lived in Maine I was yeah I
don't know cool you can just chill I
know well not being the daughter of my
parents i whatever there's not a lot of
chill I've been normal yeah
so you were in a musical household yeah
I mean obviously with your dad being
Steven Tyler what so yeah well that was
the thing my mom I only lived with my
mom oh no I didn't live with my dad or
my stepdad so she was the one that was
always in bands growing up so I would go
watch her practice and rehearse and have
gigs and stuff so cool cuz everybody
always thinks about your dad being it
for ya at the forefront of that but in
your household no and you said you were
raised as your grandma and your mama
right and your aunt and my auntie yes
yes that was a lot of wigs the village
yeah so anything in particular like your
grandma taught you that you feel like
stuck Wow I honestly I always think of
this thing which is just stop look and
listen in any situation whether when
you're nervous excited or and and just
to really like pay attention to others
and that kindness and consideration
she's an etiquette teacher we wrote a
book together but and she has always
taught me a lot about manners but that's
the one thing I've got that stuck with
me was just that really paying attention
to the people I think it just and just
thinking about ourselves and people
don't look and say hey actually how are
you really
we were discussing this in the room like
I feel like we always asked each other
like how we are and everybody says finer
okay nobody really gives you the right
answer yeah yeah so I I think that's
incredible what a great grandma to have
to teach you that early and that's
probably why you're such a kind to
awesome lady now subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel please
don't make me keep going